This morning my mother asked me if I would do the farm chores.
So I got the kids out of bed bright and early and drove over.
The first thing to do when I get there is milk Sandy,
one of our 100% grass fed, pasture raised cows.
My goal is to milk her by hand
because I like to be able to do things the traditional way.
It's definitely an art and I'm still a bit scared.
So I got some help with that? Sure.
Next I needed to filter the raw milk,
which is a quick process and removes any unwanted particles.
Sandy gives us one gallon per day,
so we freeze the milk for future usage.
Cheese, yogurt,
cream cheese, Cafire cream,
butter, ice cream, etc.
Our pasture raised chickens receive a 100% organic,
corn free, soy free,
fermented feed. The kids collect their eggs
which we will use to make the family breakfast.
We have so many eggs in storage and we love this nutrient and staple.
Next the cows and all of us
walk over to feed the Guinea fowl their breakfast.
They give us upwards of 20 eggs per day.
Their egg shells are so hard,
like a stone.
We make our way over the bridge and into the vegetable garden
where I do some much needed harvesting.
Mainly summer squashes, lettuces and broccoli.
Lastly, I get a fire started for breakfast
while the kids have a glass of fresh raw milk.